beaucoup s'attendaient à ce que le
chemin de l'école reprenne en septembre
ce ne sera pas le cas pourquoi parce que
le président de la république estime que
la situation actuelle creuse les
inégalités et crèches écoles collèges et
lycées vont donc ré ouvrir à partir du
11 mai date à laquelle confinement
général a été prolongée une décision qui
ne fait pas l'unanimité
pour certains il était grand temps de
réouvrir les établissements scolaires de
temps qu'ils sont fermés depuis le 16
mars pour d'autres cette décision est
incompréhensible pour quoi et bien parce
que ce retour en classe pourrait tout
simplement favoriser de nouvelles
contaminations
si toutes les mesures sont prises
pourquoi pas mais je pense qu'il va
falloir vraiment aménagé de façon à ce
que toutes les précautions sanitaires
soient prises et d'hygiène et forcément
pour le bien des enfants mais aussi le
bien de tous personnels les enfants sont
des porteurs qui peuvent être sain donc
ils peuvent ramener le corps aux nazis
russes à leurs proches
eux ils ne l'auront pas mais leurs
proches leur ont donc je pense que c'est
un petit peu trop tour et pourquoi les
universités ne peuvent pas reprendre
alors que les écoles primaires oui ça
devrait peut-être plus inverse
mais j'ai entendu encore une qui disait
mon fils il a 14 ans mais il faut qu'ils
aillent à l'école parce qu'on peut pas
il peut pas rester tout seul une excuse
moi mon époque à mes parents
travaillaient ma mère
une grosse douche et bain le maire
couleurs jeudi
on était tout seul l'économie a besoin
de redémarrer également un et donc on va
sortir quand même d'une période
économique qui va être faire on va
rentrer plus tôt dans une période
économique qui va être dramatique pour
les gens et pour les entreprises
et voilà il est obligé de relancer d'une
manière ou d'une autre l'économie c'est
pour ça que les gens retournent
travailler pour retourner travailler
faut que les gens mettent leurs enfants
quelque part je pense que le confinement
à isoler des enfants dans les familles
et il ya des enfants qui sont maltraités
je pense que au delà de la musau de son
2e rang d'icône renage parce qu'on leur
a tous mais s'ils pensent davantage que
le problème est lié à est liée à une
visibilité de ses enfants des services
sociaux donc l'état veut reprendre la
main sur ces enfants je pense qu on va
pas demander à deux enfants de six ans
deux gardés à 1 mètre 80 distance 20 c
c'est là que ça va moins je pense que ça
va faire plus de mal et puis les masques
déjà nous les adultes on est supporter
pas les gosses ils vont jouer avec yvon
pas le maître thibault il va tomber il
va le tourner ils vont jouer avec ils
vont s'en servir de chapeau
cette date du 11 mai pose un nombre de
questions incalculable comment faire
respecter les règles de distanciation
sociale dans les établissements
scolaires pourra-t-on fournir aide et
masco 10 millions d'élèves au million de
personnels enseignants tous les jours
les collectivités seront elles en mesure
de procéder à la désinfection des locaux
quoi qu'il en soit emmanuel macron elle
laisse le soin à son gouvernement est
bien de proposer d'ici 15 jours la
déclinaison concrète de ce retour en
classe de cette réouverture des
établissements scolaires à noter que
dans l'enseignement supérieur à les
cours ne reprendront pas avant l'été
eh bien ce sont les mots du président de
la république